I made Tanya McCoy's spaghetti Olive
angole from the White Lotus
Tanya was living my dream in the white
load of season 2 at least until you know
so I wanted to recreate elements of her
Sicilian fever dream of a trip though I
don't look like Monica VT don't have a
Vespa or Villa or a man in a very
slim-fitting suit but I do have the
ingredients for a big plate of pasta and
giant clams this dish is actually
relatively simple to make I just opened
up my clams in a deep Skillet with some
onions shallots lots of garlic and a
generous splash of wine and butter just
like I think Tanya would enjoy I toss it
all together with some salt pepper
parsley and the pasta for a dish so good
you could almost call it a full-on
Italian vacation immersive experience
right from my kitchen
[Music]
oh